german chancellor angela merkel has
appealed to voters to rally behind her
slumping conservative bloc with
elections to pick her successor less
than three weeks away while with her
party polling beneath 20 percent chance
america warned against a slide to the
left if the now leading social democrats
win the candidates bidding to succeed
miss merkel also made their cases
this may well be her last speech as
chancellor in the german bundestag
and just three weeks ahead of the
election angela merkel didn't pass on
the chance she spoke out of for her
conservatives and their candidates
taking a jab at their main competitors
citizens face a choice in a few days
either a government with the spd and the
greens that accepts the support of the
left party
or at least doesn't rule it out
or a federal government led by the cdu
and csu and army lascitas chancellor a
federal government that leads our
country into the future with measure and
moderation
it was an unusually outspoken show of
support from merkel who has mostly
stayed on the sidelines of the current
political campaign
but with her party tanking in the polls
her support might yet help stop the
slide
the debate was dominated by the campaign
all three chancellor candidates got a
chance to speak and all of them were in
full election mode
the chancellor candidate for mackel's
conservatives amin lashit praised her 16
years in office for having improved life
for many germans
[Applause]
we used to have 15 million unemployed we
had a lower gross domestic product it's
good to remind ourselves that these last
16 years were good for germany
social democrat olaf schultz is
america's current finance minister but
he is also her party's main contender in
the election
he too went on the attack
another government led by cdu csu would
cost germany prosperity and jobs
all three candidates pitched what they
would do if they are part of the
government after september's election
including the green candidate anna lena
berbach
we need a government that takes
responsibility and dares to do something
new to ensure climate-friendly
prosperity in germany and the future for
the common european union
with election day fast approaching this
last debate in the bundestag may have
set the tone for the remaining three
weeks of campaigning
all right let's bring in dwc political
correspondent nina hassan now to talk
more about what just happened today so
good to see you nina the outgoing
chancellor felt compelled to make the
case for her successor is that usual
no it isn't
angela meckle had vowed to stay out of
the election campaign her idea had been
to give amin lashed all the space that
he needed to gain himself a reputation
during this election campaign because
angela mcall knows full well that her
shoes are of course big ones to fill
she's still by far the most popular
active politician here in germany and so
early support would probably have made
anyone look small in comparison to her
but over recent days she changed her
mind she started actively giving lush at
official support and that of course has
to do with a historic downward trend in
the polls of her party
exactly poll ratings for her
conservatives are tanking um why are
they in trouble
there's a combination of reasons olaf
schultz is not making many mistakes from
social democrats but i think a lot also
has to do with a lack of support for
latit the candidate himself many even
within the conservatives are still not
convinced that he is the right candidate
it was a close race at the time between
him and bavarian state leader marco
souda and still to this day many people
openly say in this party that zida from
bavaria would have done a better job and
of course voters don't appreciate
in-party fighting but of course also
germans are now realizing that lashed is
not angela merkel the cdu is beginning
to change its face it's becoming a lot
more conservative again i mean lashed is
surrounding himself with people who
don't necessarily represent modern
values and that some of them are
traditionally neo-liberal politicians so
he's losing many people who in the past
would have voted for the cdu because of
merkel
and as we're speaking there are less
than three weeks to go uh for people to
head to the polls is everything still up
for grabs
it is certainly one of the most
interesting election campaign that i've
experienced in my life there are two
things at this point that do seem clear
one we will probably not know on
election night who the next chancellor
is going to be any party that wins the
most support will have to look for
coalition partners and here we're
looking at a whole range of coalition
options that is also something very
unusual for germany that would either
see olaf shots from the social democrats
as chancellor or amin lashed but the
other point that is also clear is that
the only party that is not part of the
coalition in negotiations is the
far-right afd all of the other parties
have ruled out governing with them but
everybody else might sit down after the
26th of september and see whether they
can form some sort of a government
together and that process might take
weeks if not months
responding
reporting thank you very much